The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GANG CHEN: OK, so
let's get started.
A lot of stuff happened
in the last lecture.
So I'll spend a
little bit more time
to review what we talked,
what are the key points here.
So what we did in
the last lecture
is to ask the question,
what are the electron energy
levels in a periodic potential.
And that's really--
the periodic means
we're start thinking
about the crystals.
And we started with one
dimensional simple pictures
where I have periodic
arrangement of atoms.
And so if you recall,
before last lecture,
what we consider
really confined states
of atom, of a molecule,
where the wave function
is spatially just around the
atom, around the molecule.
And in this periodic
structure, what
could happen is the wave
function the original belong--
electron belong to
an atom, now they
have space to flex their
wave function muscles.
It goes through
the whole crystal.
And in that expression,
what we have is
we use an extended wave
of different wave vectors.
And each of these wave
vector represent--
a wave function.
And if I have N
atoms, and wave vector
is every 2 pi, k times a every
2 pi, I have it repeating.
So at the end, I'm
drawing only 2 pi.
In fact, I'm drawing from
negative pi to plus pi.
And I'll give you the rationale
today why we draw this way.
And then, it's
important to recognize
that between minus pi
over a to plus pi over a,
we have a total of N points.
Because I have N atoms in
this periodic direction.
And each point, of course,
represents a quantum state.
Except I do not have
the spin included.
So each-- so if I have an N
points, in fact, I have 2N.
So it's symmetric from minus
pi over a to plus pi over a.
So I only draw--
you see, I only draw
the other, the one half of it.
And if I count
from here to here,
there are really two
important states.
And with that, I say if I
give hydrogen as an example,
if I could arrange them in one
dimensional periodical fashion,
then because each
hydrogen has one
electron and the absolute zero
temperature, the lowest energy
level fields.
And you will fill to
the middle of the band.
And if I have three electrons,
lithium, you'll fill to here.
It fills to the
middle of the band.
And in that-- those
are the metals.
Where are the
nonzero temperature,
there are some with very little
energy, you can move around.
Those electrons near the top,
where the uppermost energy
level that filled with electron,
this is called the Fermi level.
At absolute T, the
uppermost energy
level where electrons
are at the Fermi level.
And if you read the different
books, sometimes people will
call nonzero
temperature, they'll
say that's also Fermi level.
That is a more better way
is at nonzero temperature,
this one can shift a little
bit around that position.
And that's-- it's better to
call them chemical potential.
So different books,
sometimes they distinguish,
sometimes they do not.
A student came to
me and say what
is say-- in electrical
engineering,
for example, if you
read electronics,
they'll always call
that Fermi level.
Nonzero temperature is
always called Fermi level.
And so this is, of course,
it fills to the top.
Then there is a gap in energy.
That means no electrons can
exist with that specific energy
in the crystal.
So no waves allowed.
And so if I have two
electrons, again, at zero,
you will fill to the uppermost
of the lowest band there.
And now, because there
is a gap, electron
does not have enough energy
to go to the next level
if that gap is large.
So for a large gap, the
electron cannot move,
because there is
no quantum state.
Now, everything is filled here.
There's no more quantum state
this electron can move to.
So the Fermi exclusion
principle say
you can't have more than one
electron per quantum state.
So this is the case where
the electron in the material,
they're always a charge.
But you got the insulator.
There is low
electric conduction.
So this is the insulator.
And of course, we
spend most of time
on this one dimensional
lattice chair model.
And if you go to 3D, which
we'll talk more today,
you look at each
direction of the crystal,
you can see a
different periodicity.
And different periodicity
also means the bonding
between the atoms in
that specific direction,
the force is different.
And so you will see a
different band structure.
I'm just-- handwavingly
drawing this.
So this is A1 is one
specific direction
with that periodicity, A1.
And another crystallographic
direction could be A2.
And in fact, there are many
crystallographic directions
in the crystal.
So ideally, you know everything.
You know each direction, what
are the energy diagram, energy
of the charge.
And here, I'm drawing
two direction.
And now, this is the
minimum point here.
This is the maximum point
in the first band here.
And again, the band
gap, this is a gap here.
By the way, when I talk
about the semiconductor,
I'm talking about the
absolute gap, meaning there--
this is the highest point
where the electron fills
and lowest point that's empty.
And there is a
separation in energy.
So in this region, there's no--
in this region here, there's
no electron in the material,
in the crystal that has--
could have those energy.
That's quantum
mechanically forbidden.
That's what a real
insulator like
a glass, or quartz, if you
think about crystalline form
of glass.
This is where
electric insulator,
it has a very large bandgap.
And if this bandgap is small--
is not that large.
Let's say silicon is
1.1 electron volt,
it becomes a semiconductor.
And for semiconductors, we
have different scenarios,
where this lowest energy point,
maximum energy point, they
do not align to the
same wave vector.
That's the case for silicon.
And that's an indirect
gap semiconductor.
So we have different
type of semiconductors.
We have direct gap.
We have indirect gap.
Direct gap is when
the conduction
and the valence bands,
so the upper band,
we say conduction a
lower band is valence.
So they are happening--
the minimum and maximum is
at the same wave vector.
While indirect is different.
It could be here is the energy.
Here is the wave vector.
And they may happen at
different wave vectors.
And this makes an
important distinction
between gallium arsenide,
which is a direct gap
semiconductor with a bandgap of
1.4 electron volt and silicon,
which is an indirect
gap semiconductor
with a bandgap of 1.1
And you see most computer
chips are made of silicon.
But most laser pointers,
made of gallium arsenide.
This one, when you want to
make a light active device,
direct gap is usually better,
because you need a light.
Light itself do not
have much momentum.
So here, k is the momentum.
So h bar k is what we
call crystal momentum.
It has some differences from the
real momentum of the electrons.
But say, we're not getting
into that subtle difference.
In typical way, you
can think is this
is when I think about
momentum conservation of say,
a light comes in, interact
with the electron.
I use h bar k of the
electron in the crystal.
Used h bar k for the photon.
Now, the difference, of course,
remember k is 2 pi lambda.
That's magnitude.
So if you look at here in
crystal, my lattice constant,
this is pi over a.
That's angstrom in
lambda wavelengths.
And photon lambda is a micron.
So the photon momentum is
almost negligible, very small.
And the electron
momentum, in this case,
if they are different,
they're very large.
That's why indirect gap
semiconductors do not absorb
well, do not absorb light well.
That's a big problem when
you make silicon solar cells.
You need a lot of materials
to absorb the photon.
So this is a direct
gap, indirect gap.
And a little bit more
terminology for semiconductors.
And if I do not put impurities,
do not put any, say,
other atoms,
silicon, for example,
at the absolute
zero temperature,
the electrons will be here.
That's the uppermost
energy level.
That's the absolute zero
temperature, the Fermi level,
where the Fermi level is.
And now, at nonzero
temperature, some electrons
gain enough thermal energy
because of the Boltzmann
statistics.
There are always electron
has distribution.
And some electrons
move from here to here.
And that leaves
behind empty states.
And because empty
states, the electron
here, free electron here,
are very happy because there
are a lot of empty
states, many electron here
are also happy because
now they finally have
a little bit of room to wiggle.
So the ones on the bottom,
rather than describing
the motion of all
those electrons,
fill the electron,
equivalent terminology
is describe the motion
of those empty states.
That's holes.
And holes, when I
think about holes,
energy is increasing
this way, because it's
the negative of the electron.
When I think about
electrons, the energy
is increasing this way.
So when I look at
this band diagram,
when I think about
electron hole,
I actually say this direction
is energy increasing for hole.
That's the energy
increasing for electron.
So we have electrons.
We have holes.
And here, where the electron
move is the conduction band.
And whre the hole move, this
one is the valence band.
And if it's a true intrinsic
semiconductor without doping,
absolute zero is the insulator.
Because it's for all
the charges here,
and there's no moveable charge.
So there are no empty states
for the electron to move.
But see, normally, I
do not deal with-- when
I use a semiconductor
device, I want
to have a specific either
electron as a majority
or hole as majority.
So I dope it.
So that's a intrinsic/extrinsic
semiconductor difference.
So we have intrinsic, that's
when we do not dope it.
And extrinsic, when we dope it.
And when we dope, we can
dope with the n-type,
when I put the phosphor.
Or I dope p-type.
So those are the semiconductors.
And one more thing
I want to introduce.
This is-- if I look
at the energy electron
at the bottom or
hole at the top.
And in fact, that's
the bottom of the hole,
and when I do the--
because this is at a
minimum/maximum point.
So most of the time, the
charge in semiconductor,
when you do not deal
with the heavily doped,
they are only at the
bottom or top region here.
And because of the
minimum/maximum,
so I can use approximation.
I can expand the potential
electrical energy
around the minimum/maximum.
So if I do an expansion,
typical expansion, So
energy as a function of
k, and I'm writing 1D.
You can say k in real crystal,
in each crystallographic
direction, has a k.
So I'm not writing
in vector form.
But I can expand that.
Let's say here, this is
EC conduction band edge.
This is a k0.
That's where the
minimum happens.
So I'm going to expand
this as an EC k0.
That's the first term
of the expansion.
And the second term, dE
dk k0 and the k minus k0.
And the last term is a dE dk
square and k minus k0 square.
So this term, because
of maximum/minimum,
is 0 as long as I do not
have a sharp turning.
It's a linear profile.
I cannot make that
approximation.
So normally, this is 0.
And this one, let me write
it into a form that's nicer.
So I can write this h
square k minus k0 square
and divide it by,
say, 2m, m as m star.
So just a symbol.
So this m star, because
I have h bar square,
so I will have--
in the denominator,
I will add h bar square.
And the dE dk square.
Do I?
OK, right, so you
can say this m star
is a second order to derivative
of this curve at the bottom.
So if it's-- the
m star is large.
How is that shape looking like?
Flat.
m bar is small.
That shape, the parabola,
local parabola, is narrow.
m star is large, the
local parabola is fat.
So this mass is like--
in fact, it has a unit of mass.
If I write a free electron,
this hk is the momentum.
Dive by 2m, that's
the kinetic energy.
So by writing to this,
I introduce this m star
as an effective mass.
And using this
effective mass, this
is hk, that's more like
a kinetic energy term.
And it's a potential
energy term.
So I can describe,
now, the electron
in this small
band, the transport
as essentially inside the
crystal as a free electron
but with a different
mass, m star.
And in fact, and
now you can say,
because this k in a real
crystal in different direction
is different, so the mass
in different direction
is different.
So in fact, many
times, this m star
is written as a tensor, rather
than just a single value there.
And that depends on
different materials.
So this is both a
overview of last lecture
and also some expansion in
terms of the effect of mass.
And where I'm going today
is continue this 3D picture.
Now we have 1D picture,
we're going 3D.
So in the 3D, I want to
first talk about the crystal
structure to get more familiar.
Then, I will talk about what are
the bonding between the atoms
that hold the crystal together.
And finally, we'll use a
mathematical terminology
is how we can--
it's a periodic
function in 3D and what
are the corresponding
Fourier transform.
We did a one-dimensional,
we say this k essentially
are the Fourier transform.
So this is where
we're going today.
Let's look at the
crystal structures first.
And at the end of
the lecture, I'll
show the best is by looking
at it more visually.
I can't draw that way.
So I'll use a 2D as an example.
But at the end, we'll
look at the 3D online.
So crystals can be
described-- the most important
characteristic of crystal
is the periodicity, periodic
arrangement of atoms.
And they have
different atoms putting
into the same structure.
So a crystal we can
describe as a lattice,
which is a mathematical
concept plus basis.
So lattice is a periodic
arrangement of points in space.
And it's mathematical concept.
Now devoid of any
real materials.
And by doing that,
you can actually
classify different structures
of these periodic points.
So let's take a look at a
a simple 2D, like I said.
And 2D, but there
is a center point.
2D structure,
periodic arrangement.
And we introduce a
few basic terminology.
One is primitive lattice vector.
So in 3D, will be a1, a2, a3.
In 2D, of course,
we only have two.
And what is a primitive
lattice vector?
It's a set of vector that I
can use the linear combination
to reach all other
points by integers.
So I can use this
primitive lattice vector
to construct a translation
vector n1 a1 plus n2 a2 plus n3
a3 while n1, n2,
n3 are integers.
OK, so this is the
primitive lattice vector.
And the problem is
if I look at this 2D,
I have a different ways to
choose the primitive lattice
vector.
Here is one way.
If I have this one and this one.
If you look at this,
I can use these two
and the linear
combination of this two
to reach any other points.
So this is, let's say,
a1 and this is a2.
And of course, you could
also choose a different one.
You can choose this
one and this one.
So one of the challenge is
how to narrow down our choice,
how to uniquely define this
choice of primitive lattice
vectors.
The other is a
conventional unit cell.
So primitive lattice
vector, those vectors
will form a unit
area or unit volume.
so?
In 2D is by this unit area.
If I choose this,
this is my unit area.
And I just repeat it, I
will pile up the 2D space
without any voids.
And the similarly, in 3D, I
choose my primitive-- this unit
vector from a volume.
That's a primitive unit cell.
So this will form a
primitive unit cell.
And so this is the one
choice of the vectors.
And the other choice
is conventional.
You can say unit cell.
And say if you look
at this, it probably
is much easier if you choose
this as your unit cell.
It looks more regular.
And if you look at the
difference of a primitive unit
cell and the
conventional unit cell.
A primitive unit cell, each
of the cells has the only one
lattice point, equivalently.
This is because although
this primitive unit
cell has four lattice points,
each of this lattice ts
is shared by four unit cells.
So each of the
lattice point is 1/4.
You add up, it's one
point, one lattice point
in one primitive unit cell.
But if I take this
conventional one,
you can say this one is shared
by four, So 1/4, 1/4, that's--
in my current drawing, there are
two points, two lattice points
in one conventional unit cell.
And they are-- so like I said,
one of the challenge is even
if I take a primitive unit cell,
each of the cell is one lattice
point, I do not
have a unique way--
the way I have many choices.
So there is a cumbersome,
but the only way to do it,
to define a primitive unit cell.
And this is a
Wigner-Seitz construction.
So let me extend
this drawing here.
I will extend to this
side to make it clear.
So one way to construct this
is to take any of these lattice
point, here is a
lattice point, I
collect all the
neighboring lattice points.
So I connect with all
the neighboring points.
And then I take the
bisect of those points
here, of these lines.
So this is the bisect.
And here is bisect.
And here is a bisect.
And you have another point here.
And it turns out this one
is not a regular cell.
It doesn't look very
good, but it's a unique.
Because any crystal structure,
I can take lattice point.
I connect all the
neighboring points.
I take the bisects.
And the minimum volume in
this case of area, the form
is a primitive unit cell.
And I can use that to stack
together and form-- and fill
the whole space
without the voids.
So it's not the
easiest construction,
but it's a unique construction.
And this is for the
Wigner-Seitz construction.
Wigner-Seitz unit cell.
Wigner-Seitz cell, because
it's always-- this construction
always give you unit cell.
OK, so this unit
cell gives you--
now we have the
primitive lattice vector,
the primitive unit cell.
And as I said, this lattice
is a mathematical concept.
So there are different--
required different symmetry.
The most-- in 3D, for example,
the easiest is a triclinic unit
cell that I can
stack and form the--
form the whole space,
fill the whole space.
So there is no symmetry.
The angle, there's
no line of degree.
And the lattice constant
between here-- the unit
cell of the lattice comes in
each direction are different.
So this is a general one.
But then there are
different symmetry.
If you add the
symmetries, it turns out
there are only a total of 14
types of the crystal lattice.
And I will defer this later
on to show you on computer.
And these are the 14 types,
also called the Bravais lattice.
So well look at this
in computer later on.
And one more convention
of this lattice,
the mathematical description, is
the different crystallographic
plans.
So if I take a cubic
structure, a unit seal that's
made of cube, my
question is how I
would denote different faces,
different crystallographic
directions.
And the different
crystallographic planes.
And the convention
that's usually
used in define the
crystallographic planes,
let's say this is 3D.
I have a1, a2, a3.
And I have any crystallographic
plane, for example,
from here, going here.
This is the middle point.
And I could have this point.
So this form a crystallographic
plan, any of those.
So if I have a plan that
intersect within the unit cell,
let's say at one point--
in a1 direction, I have an
intersection point, a2, a3.
Let me give you an arbitrary
number as an example.
So this is 0.8 in terms of
the total length of unit cell.
And here is the 0.4.
And here is 0.6.
This is a plane within
that cube there.
And the way I label these planes
is this Miller index method.
And you take a
first stab, you take
a reciprocal of those numbers.
The reciprocal is 0.8,
0.4, and then say 0.6.
You take, say, inverse
of those intersects
and then you'll reduce
these two integers.
You multiply by
the common factors.
So if we multiply, reduce this
to integer, I multiply by 2.4.
And I get a 3, 6, 4.
So that's the crystallographic
plan that we just draw.
This is the convention.
And you say that's
pretty cumbersome.
Why you take the inverse?
That's one way to think about
this is if I look at this cube
again, for example,
this surface here,
and if I do not take an
inverse, you see my intersect.
So this is a1.
This is a2.
And this is a3.
And if I look at this surface
here, that intersect here is 1.
And the other two
direction is infinite.
So this surface, there
will be intersect is
1, infinite, infinite.
And I guess people
don't like the infinite,
so take an inverse.
And that becomes 1, 0, 0 plane.
So that's just the
convention of denoting
specific
crystallographic planes.
OK, now, here is so
far is mathematics.
So we say the lattice
point is abstract.
There's no mass.
Just periodic array.
And there are 14 types.
But we have so many
variations in real world
different crystals,
different materials.
So structurally,
among the 14 types,
the difference is really
at each lattice point,
what do you put there?
What you put there are each
lattice point is a basis.
And you can put a single
atom at each lattice point.
You can put two atoms
at each lattice point.
Or put the molecule
So salt is common.
Salt is among the
14 types later on,
is face centered cubic, with
a cubic structure with one
atom at the face.
Let's say at each of
those lattice point,
you actually put a
sodium and chloride atom.
So OK, each lattice
point doesn't mean
they occupy the same space.
It's just periodically, you
can say, OK, this is a sodium.
And another direction,
you have chloride.
You just repeat that
for each lattice point.
This will become
more clear later on
as we look at the computer.
I can't draw very well,
so I will rely on that.
And similarly, silicon crystal.
And silicon crystal, it turns
out, at each lattice point,
you put two silicon,
a silicon and silicon.
So again, that's a--
it's the same everywhere
is a silicon atom.
But if you look at
the crystal itself,
or you actually put two silicon
atoms in specific direction
with specific angle that
from the silicon crystal.
So those are the basis for
what we call lattice plus basis
together to form the crystal.
OK, let's hold that we'll
come back and look at it.
What we want to talk next.
So here is a description for
the crystal structure right.
And next, we want to
answer what is the bonding
between the crystals.
So bonding potentials,
and what really hold
the material together, I think
I said this before, are charge.
It's the electron.
So I say electron is the
glue for the materials.
And when we have--
the typical potential we I
have two atoms put in close
together, so a typical
potential curve
is this is the separation.
And this is the potential,
interatomic potential.
And they always look like this.
When they are far apart,
they are attractive.
And when they are close to
each other, they are repulsive.
That's a typical
interatomic potential.
And the minimal energy point
is where the separation
will be most stable.
So it turns out this--
why you have
repulsive, that's when
they, for example,
the nucleus of the two
atom, positive charge, start to
overlap, influence each other,
and that's always--
that's what cause repulsive.
And nuclear, of course, that's
when they get really close.
So repulsive part is
actually easier to describe.
Repulsive and typical
potential form
for the repulsive part as
a function of separation,
one is people often use
is the 12th power law,
very sharp function, 12th power.
This is Lennard-Jones type.
And the other is use a
exponential function.
U0 exponential minus r
[INAUDIBLE],, and [INAUDIBLE]
is the characteristic length.
And this is the
form, Born-Mayer.
So repulsive, that's
the typical form
that people use to describe
the repulsive potential.
And what really differ
between different crystals
is the attractive part.
So attractive potential, and I
said the electron is the glue.
So even for the least
strongly bonded Crystal,
it's still due to electron.
These are the crystal formed
by inert atoms, argon crystal.
Argon is a gas.
But if you cool it
to low temperature,
it actually form crystal.
So we already learned
before, argon,
why it's m because the time
electron filled close to the,
let's say--
of course which line
it is there, I forgot--
[INAUDIBLE] three or four.
So it fills close shell.
And there's no-- so
each atom is neutral.
So even in this neutral atom,
remember that atom always
have nuclei and the electrons.
So when you put them
together, what's
the interaction, why they
could have attractive
is this positive nuclei
will attract the electrons
in the neighboring atom.
And similarly, the
electron of this atom
will attract the nuclei
in the neighbor atom.
So these are the
dipole-dipole interaction.
So you will polarize,
mutual polarize each other.
And that create
attractive force.
So this attractive
force is Van der Waals.
And the attractive is A to
the separation sixth power.
And repulsive is positive.
Attractive is negative.
And so by putting the
crystal together, forming
argon crystal, what we have
is when they are very close,
it's repulsive.
When they are far apart,
they are attractive.
But of course, real
crystal has many atoms,
periodic arrangement.
So we want to--
a stable crystal is when the
total energy is minimized.
So if I have many
atoms together,
I minimize the total energy.
So if I have the total
energy of the crystal,
if I denote the atoms as,
say, sum i over j pairwise,
because of what I have here is
between two atoms, so atom i
and atom j.
And sum up all the atoms.
And the i does not equal
to j, because I'm looking
at the mutual interactions.
And I have here
the Lennard-Jones.
That's B r ij 12.
ij is the separation
between the two crystals.
If it's a cubic, you
can calculate no matter
how far apart in terms
of unit constant.
And then mass BA r ij 6th power.
So you-- this is total energy.
And when the crystal
is stable is you
take the r 1, 2, for example.
1, 2 is the unit constant, the
constant between two neighbor
atoms.
You can always
express r ij between--
further away in terms
of if you have a cube.
You can express
any further points
in terms of the smallest
lattice constant.
And you can take it
a derivative of that
in terms of lattice constant.
And that'll give you where
the crystal is stable,
what's the corresponding
lattice constant.
So this is the
simplest potential.
That's the Van der
Waals potential.
And correspondingly,
those kind of crystal
is called the Van
der Waals crystal.
Argon and krypton, those
crystals are Van der Waals.
So I remember, you
see the Superman.
There's this Krypton.
I don't know what's the
condensate or the temperature.
I haven't checked
what's the temperature.
And it's not a very
strong bonding.
And secondly, whether--
let's look at-- this
is where it's really the
Van der Waals attraction.
And the next type of attraction
that's easier to deal with
is if you have salt.
And in the case of salt,
sodium chloride, what
happens is the sodium,
the electron has one sodium,
as I say, one other electron.
You completely lose
it to the chloride.
So sodium is a positive charge.
And chloride is a
negative charge.
And in this kind of
periodic arrangement,
you have attraction.
If sodium sees sodium atom,
it's a positive-positive.
It's a repulsion.
It sees a chloride
atom, it's attraction.
So at the end, whether
you have a stable crystal
is you put all those
energy together,
you minimize them
together to get--
in addition to the repulsive,
we can put them too close.
So in ionic crystal,
the attractive potential
for any atom i, attractive part,
is it has to be attractive.
The lattice effect
has to be attractive,
otherwise everything
is repulsive.
You don't have a crystal.
So this atom i, you look
at the surrounding sodium.
You look at the surrounding--
the next atom could
be chloride.
So you sum of them up.
And they look at the next shell.
That'd be sodium again.
That's repulsive.
And you do all this summation.
So we have this summation
of all other atoms.
And if they are, say, charged--
each atom is with
charge q, so plus minus
to represent it's repulsive
or attractive due to electron
Coulomb interaction, r ij.
So this is the
Coulomb interaction.
And it's a very
simple intellectually.
And again, you can
express further atoms,
let's say, in other
locations, if this
is the one you consider at
any other location in terms
of unit constant.
And so they this one,
in fact, sometimes
people write into alpha square,
alpha q square, 4 pi epsilon 0.
And the R0, R0 is the
nearest neighbor distance.
So that's the last
neighbor distance.
And this alpha is a constant
for different crystals.
You do your structure,
so you sum it up.
It becomes just dependent
on crystal structure.
And this is a Madeling constant.
So with this, and also
with the repulsive part,
you add them together,
the whole crystal,
you find out what's
the last neighbor
separation that minimize
total ionic crystal energy.
And that's the stable
crystal structure.
So having said this,
if you do your--
this is, of course, the minimum.
This is zero point.
It doesn't include temperature.
Some of you may do molecular
dynamics simulation,
for example.
And in that case, at
a nonzero temperature,
you write it f equal to ma.
And your f is this kind
of potential interaction.
And that separation, now, is
not the ideal lattice constant,
because the atoms jiggle around.
So this separation
of function of time.
And that dealing with ionic
force become more challenging.
In fact, that's more challenging
than covalent in certain sense,
because this dies
out very slowly.
1 over r dies out very slowly.
And that means you need to
include a lot of atoms together
to do your simulation,
increase your domain
size when you do a simulation.
If the force is short range,
it's much easier to simulate.
So now we have ionic and
the next is covalent.
Covalent, so I have given
covalent example before.
And this is when two hydrogen
atoms form a hydrogen molecule.
So when we have two hydrogen
atoms form hydrogen molecule,
And the lower energy
state is that when
the electron, because
of the Pauli exclusion,
the hydrogen atom energy level
split into sigma and sigma star
sigma bonds.
They lower band one is when
the electron orbital is
like what I draw here.
And you can see the electron
is orbited between two hydrogen
and has directionalites.
And those are the
covalent bonds.
And if you form a crystal,
so again, 2D for simplicity.
So you have directionality
in this one.
You have directionality in
here, directionality here.
So these are the regions
where, most likely,
you find the electrons.
And in this region,
you don't find--
the probability of
finding electron is small.
So the bonds has directionality.
Those are the covalent bond.
And now, the next one is if
this expand, start to overlap,
and the fill the whole
space, those covalent.
The electron can go anywhere.
That becomes--
under that picture,
I come to the metallic bonds.
Electron become free,
it's a metallic bonding.
So covalent is strongest
bonding among the--
for the crystals.
And in person, when we deal
with the water, liquid,
there's also a hydrogen bond.
What is hydrogen bond?
And I think you all know.
So if I have H2O, So I have--
say this is a hydrogen, this
is a hydrogen, this is oxygen.
And it has some
directionality in bond angle.
That's a single water molecule.
And now, when you bring
your next molecule,
oxygen will form some bonding
rather than just an electron
shared between one hydrogen H2O
molecule, they're [INAUDIBLE]
bond between this oxygen
and next hydrogen.
That's your hydrogen bond.
So what I have talked so far
is the periodic structure
of crystal and basic location
of periodic structure.
And then we talked
about the bonding,
what holds the atoms together,
different forms of bonds.
And next, I want come back
to this periodic structure.
I'm going to talk to you,
very mathematical concept.
And this is a Fourier transform.
And if you're
electrical engineer,
you're familiar with
the frequency domain.
And the question
is-- we mentioned
this in different occasions,
like the last time when
talk about the von Karman
periodic boundary condition.
Last time, when we talk about
von Karman periodic boundary
conditions, we say a
one dimensional lattice
chain of length L has N atoms.
And von Karman periodic boundary
conditions say, x plus L
equals psi x.
And from there, we
use the block theorem.
Because this one is x
exponential mass i k,
which is the wave through
the whole lattice.
L is NA.
And that equals psi x.
So this is a block
theorem from--
this equals-- so
this y equals 1.
That's why we get a k
equals plus minus 2 and 2
n pi divide by capital NA.
So this is how we got--
one way we got it,
from block theorem,
allowable wave vector k.
And the other way we got,
we explain it is I just
have a wave function here.
I want to expand in Fourier
space, in Fourier series.
So this equivalent,
essentially, this
say I have periodic
function I want to use.
Here is extended
wave in block wave.
The other one, once you
expand into Fourier series,
you still get a wave vector.
You got the extended wave
through the whole region.
This is 1D.
1D, I think you're all
probably comfortable,
because it's just a
corresponding time, time
into 1D space.
Now, I'm asking you
to construct a 3D,
because a crystal
is periodic in 3D.
My wave function, I'm going
to write, in general case,
a wave function at any
location plus any translation
of wave vector, that's periodic.
Or you say a primitive lattice
vector and that equals--
so now I have a 3D.
Rather than writing 1D, can you
do the Fourier representation?
So this is why we introduce
the reciprocal lattice.
And turns out, if you look at
the 1D here, the period is a.
And in your
denominator, you have a.
So it's the inverse
of that period.
So the way I do 3D construction
of that period unit vector,
because the 3D--
so a real space 3D is inverted
into Fourier space 3D.
And the Fourier space,
I also correspondingly
have a primitive unit vector,
a primitive unit cell,
and Wigner-Seitz construction.
And the way I construct this
reciprocal primitive lattice
factor is if I have the a1,
a2, a3 as the real space
primitive lattice vector, and
then the reciprocal space is b1
equals 2 pi.
So that's my 2 pi,
length becomes a volume.
So length becomes volume.
And here, I have a2 times a3.
And that permute.
The subscript, then I b2
is 2 pi volume a3 times a1.
This a cross vector product.
And the 2 pi wave a1 times a2.
And this ensure me, that's
the corresponding vector
in the Fourier space of this
3D periodic space, real space.
You will see why.
Let me give a few
more points here.
And so with that,
I can construct--
this is my primitive unit
vector in the reciprocal space.
So the translational vector,
so any of this m1 b1 and m2 b2
plus m3 b3, any of
this combination
give me one point, the lattice
point in the reciprocal space.
So this will make a periodic
real space reciprocal space.
And that's reciprocal
of real space.
It turns out that
sometimes I joke,
physicist live not
in the real world,
you're living in the
reciprocal world.
That's because most
of the time, you
see everything is drawn in
terms of the wave vectors.
And you can, of course,
construct your unit cell,
primitive unit cell,
Wigner-Seitz cell
based on these lattice points.
And now if you have--
for example, you
have your function.
That's a periodic-- any function
that's a periodic, r plus T.
And the way you do
your Fourier transform,
if this is due to
this periodicity,
you can write this function
in Fourier series, 3D
rather than 1D Fourier series.
Now you write 3D Fourier series.
And the Fourier
series is U r equals--
and here is b.
Fourier constant, UG exponential
ir times G. So r times k.
And this is a sum up over
all G's, or all those lattice
points.
And I will not--
I will not say prove.
But I will use the--
I'll do that proof
in the next lecture.
The point of this
recipricoal space,
what you could use, it's
very easy, actually doing,
when you do an experiment,
when you do a transmission
electron--
say, diffraction pattern, it
turns out that what you map out
are the reciprocal space.
You can actually easily map
out with this reciprocal space.
And so if you have object
crystal, periodic structure.
You shoot a wave comes in,
and you have diffraction.
And some of you
have seen gradients.
How many of you have seen
gradients, gradient structure.
So it turns out that any
periodic structure, next time
I'll bring one, you shoot
a light onto a gradient,
you only say the diffraction,
the light in the reflecting,
in discrete spots.
So again, if I have a
periodic arrangement of atoms,
and what you'll see is
only in certain directions,
you will see the night come out.
Or this is not light.
This called the electron
beam when you do transmission
electron micrograph.
Or it could be X-ray.
Why you use the X-ray?
Because the X-ray wavelengths
can be very short comparable
to the lattice constant.
And in that case, say, if
you satisfy this gradient's
condition, let me write
down the condition,
I'll prove it in
the next lecture.
So your condition is if this is
the wave vector of the incident
wave, this is the wave vector
of the reflective wave.
And you will have
ki minus kf equals--
plus G equals 0.
So you see G is the lattice
point in the reciprocal space.
And say this is
incident reflected.
And coming back to y at
the beginning, we draw--
the electron energy
dispersion, this is pi over a.
And we only draw over pi over a.
This pi over a, turns out that's
the Wigner-Seitz cell boundary
in the reciprocal space.
So having said all
this, I think we really
need to look at some pictures.
Let's look at the--
So this Google
Image is wonderful.
I don't need to draw anything.
Let's first look either
the Bravais lattice, right?
And you can see,
there are 14 type.
Here is triclinic.
Different angle, different
lattice constant.
And here, the simplest
is a simple cube.
This is a combination of cell.
So if I put a center here, put
a lattice point at the center,
then this simple cube,
I got a body center.
And then if I put a lattice
point at every face,
I get a face center.
In this conventional
unit cell, you
can have more than
one lattice point.
In primitive unit cell, you can
only have one lattice point.
So if you look at
the body center,
how many lattice points
I have equivalent?
Two, right?
Because each of these
corners is shared by eight.
So that's 1/8.
So simple cubic, I have one.
Body center, I have two.
How about face center?
Four, right?
Because every phase,
you have six face.
And every face is shared by 2.
So that's the 1/2.
And that's the 3 plus
1 of the eight corners.
So it gives you--
so this is a--
if you look at the
form total 14 type.
And hexagonal is
also interesting,
because a lot of people
are interested in graphite.
And graphite is a
hexagonal structure.
So let's look at--
so this is the Bravais lattice.
Let's look at some real
crystal structures.
So starting with
sodium chloride.
It's probably easier.
Let's see a look at this here.
If you see, sodium chloride.
And here, if we look at
sodium atom, this is--
here at the center,
you have sodium.
So the basis is
between here and here.
That's a molecule you
put the sodium chloride.
And then every point, you
can look at that same sodium
chloride, you repeat that
basis at each lattice point.
And we'll look at
silicon structure.
Silicon.
If you look at silicon
crystal, what you have here,
again, this is a face Center.
There is one point here.
But you have, each point, you
actually put the two atoms,
silicon.
At this point and this
point, this is not any--
this is 1/4, 1/4, 1/4 point.
So between 0, 0, 0,
and 1/4, 1/4, 1/4,
you're repeating that structure
to each lattice point.
So it turns out this atom, there
is more like a tetragular form.
It's equidistant between
this and this center
and this center.
So it's at each lattice
point, you put a basis.
You put, say, a molecule
or atoms, or two atoms
or three atoms, many atoms.
You can have polymers
from crystal.
And that could be
a very large basis.
Reciprocal space.
Let's see.
I don't like this.
Wigner-Seitz, OK,
so you can see this
is a construction of a
Wigner-Seitz unit cell.
So you have a point
in the center.
If you from center,
to this direction,
you take the midpoint, you cut--
I think you cut this plane.
So the Wigner-Seitz
cell looks, in 3D,
it could be very irregular.
But that's a unique
way for constructing.
There's no ambiguity.
And each lattice
type you construct,
you can construct a
corresponding Wigner-Seitz unit
cell.
So reciprocal-- I
still on Google.
Unit cell, let's see this.
No.
Let's get-- do I
have a simpler--
So this is now getting
more to what people usually
draw FCC structure,
face centered cubic.
They will say, OK,
they actually have
specific location from gamma
to L. That's 1, 1, 1 direction.
And the way I look at this, the
shortest distance, as I say,
because of--
1, 1, 1 is the longer
distance in real space.
And inverse is the
shortest distance.
So I'll say that's
the 1, 1, 1 direction.
This is the 1, 0, 0
direction, longest distance.
And so those are the very
complicated reciprocal space.
And coming back to here,
this is the Bragg condition.
We'll prove it next time.
I don't actually know whether
it's one G or two G. Two G's?
Let's see.
OK, so if you do your--
you can map this out,
so TM diffraction.
So if you do a transmission
electron micrograph,
microscopy, we
mentioned TM is actually
electrons very high velocity.
And under that high velocity,
the electron wavelengths
are short comparable to
the lattice constant.
So now, you go through a
thin specimen, typically
1,000, 2,000 angstrom maximum.
You go through there.
And even though it's
1,000 angstrom, remember,
the large constant
is a few angstroms.
So you've got 1,000 periods.
And so it's a
periodic structure.
And depend on-- so you
rotate your crystals,
you can look at a
different diffraction spot.
In those dark regions, you don't
say the electron going there.
That's a result of
the wave diffraction.
And again, we'll show this,
we'll prove this later on.
And that's the
electron diffraction.
Let's look at the
X-ray diffraction.
So X-ray diffraction,
again, is an optical wave.
And what you show-- what
people will say is that people,
they don't-- the image, the
detector, is typically a line.
So by rotating the angle
of X-ray incidence,
you see the peaks.
again, that's the Bragg
condition requirement.
And let's see whether
there are the clean ones.
View some of these clean peaks.
Oh, I like this one.
Doesn't look like I
can show this one.
OK, so you can see some--
so basically, people
have built libraries.
And sometimes, you don't
even know what you have.
You get all those peaks,
you search the library.
And you find out what
the materials you have.
And one more time,
going into next time,
I'm not going to
go through this.
Here, it's no longer
a single spot.
Why?
That's because there's
not a single crystal.
It's a polycrystal.
So you've got a range.
So this is all coming back
to the reciprocal space.
You can rotate your crystal,
rotate your angle of incidence
in X-ray, change your
angle of incidence.
So you can map out the
what's the lattice constant.
What are the range of--
arrangement of atoms.
OK, I'll stop here.